Of many millions of astronomical bodies.
The solar system is comprised of only a few thousand have been pinpoint so far
with the inner part of the system investigated sufficiently. Well,
by now its vast expanses beyond Neptune's orbit still remain to
be explored. There is a great number of object it's out there,
but mankind is aware only of the largest ones today.
I'm going to tell you about one of them Mackey Mackey,
which is one of the biggest objects in the Kip belt.
The first outer space. It was Pluto.
That was the first astronomical body discovered beyond Neptune's orbit.
It happened over 90 years ago, back in 1930.
Unfortunately the technologies of the day were not advanced enough to be able to
detect dim objects at large distances.
That is why it took another 47 years before another discovery of a
celestial object in that area of space had been made in
1978.
Sharon was discovered and the first asteroid beyond Pluto orbit Albian
was detected in 1992.
The 1990s proved to be fruit in terms of discovering a string of
Trani union Celest steel bodies. But at the beginning of the 21st century,
there was a positive boom in exploring remote parts of the Sola system.
That is when the prominent team of researchers, Michael Brown,
David Rabinovitz and Chadwick Tru pinpointed the most well known space
objects be on UNE orbit among these one designated
2005 F Y nine can be singled out later on.
It was to be renamed into Mackey Mackey.
This exoplanet was first seen in images taken on the 31st of March,
2005 and four months later on the
29th of July information about the newly discovered celestial object
was made available to the general public.
After the official statement from the research group,
when discovered the planetoid was just slightly dimer than Pluto as
for its location. At the time,
it was much higher than the ecliptic plane in region of the constellation com
bur ISIS. Thanks to archive images.
Maki Mackey has been thoroughly studied by now.
The planetoids eccentricity isn't big at just north 0.1 62.
The angle between the planetoids orbit and the ecliptic plane is 29 degrees,
which is why this all object bright and large as it is.
Hadn't been noticed before when exploring those parts of our
system. The first researchers had focused on the ecliptic plane,
as they assumed that the chances of discovering new celestial bodies there were
higher at the time. However,
the planetoid was located in the upper part of its orbit,
which is why the researchers couldn't see it.
Maki Maki completes a full orbit around the system center every 306 years.
It is currently 52.5 astronomical its away from the sun.
The planetoid is going to reach its EIL in the year 2033 with a
distance to the sun,
52.82 astronomical units having receded from the parent star and reached its
Furst point from it. Maki Maia will start approaching it.
The planetoid is estimated to reach Chi Perian in the year 2187
with the distance, separating it from the sun being 38 astronomical units.
At that point
on the planetoids closest approach to the system center,
its luminosity will be almost the same as start of Pluto,
which will enable scientists to collect more accurate day later about it
in terms of its orbits parameters.
The dwarf planet falls into the category of the so-called classical objects to
the Kip about or QB one oh unlike Latinos,
which are in orbital resonance with Neptune QB,
one OHS like white far from this icy giant.
That is why the GRA influence exerted by N you know them is quite
negligible on the 23rd of April,
2011 Mac Mackey's disc was passing in front of a dim star in the constellation
com ISIS, thanks to this eclipse.
It was possible to estimate the planetoid size rather accurately
its equatorial diameter measures one and half thousand kilometers
its polar diameter on the other hand,
turned out to be 1,430 kilometers,
which is around 62% that of Pluto.
This earns Maki Maki the status of the fourth largest transept union object
coming after Pluto, Aris and Hal. However,
it may still be beaten by goong whose parameters still haven't been estimated
with a satisfying degree of accuracy.
Maki Mac's exact mass still remains to be found out.
The planetoids average density is estimated at approximately 1.7 grams
per cubic centimeter, which is slightly lower than that. Of Pluto.
This information allows us to gauge to dwarf planets mass at roughly three times
10 to the power of 21 kilograms.
Incidentally, it is 4% that of the moon
Maki Mackey's rotation period is a around 22 and a half hours,
which is quite a lot for it. Whaf planet.
It has known that the planetoid faces the earth with its equator.
Although the tilt of its axis with respect to the orbital plane hasn't been
estimated yet,
Maki Mackey is admittedly a rather bright object.
The average ratio of its actual brightness equals around north 0.8.
First spectral analysis revealed that the planetoid surface is not homogeneous.
Most of it shows a high brightness ratio reaching 90%
still up to 7% of the dwarf planet surface is dotted with dark spots
absorbing up to 98% of the light. She on it,
these patches are thought to be areas of surface made up of rocks that are
peculiar to the planetoid.
Strangely enough later observations carried out using the Galileo national
telescope showed Mackey Mackey's surface is rather homogeneous.
The dark spots reportedly seen on it may have been errors of observation or
reflections of an unknown satellite that happened to be passing over the dwarf
planets surface. That is why further observations are needed. Tos settle.
The question
observations and spectral analysis revealed that Maki Maki's surface is almost
as brightest out of Pluto.
It consists for the most part of methane ethane and a very small amount of
nitrogen continuous exposure to powerful ultraviolet trays is thought
to have produced thorough complex hydrocarbon polymers containing
nitrogen.
It is thorough that give me Thane snow on the surfaces of transept objects.
A typical Redish hu
Maki Mackey's surface temperature is currently estimated at around 29 Calvin or
244 degrees Celsius below zero.
When MACI Mackey is in its per Heian,
the temperature slightly rises to around 34 Calvin or
239 degrees Celsius is below zero as the melting point of
nitrogen and methane is much higher.
It is logical to assume that the planetoid must be covered with red snow made up
of methane mixed with ethane, ni gins,
interestingly observations and estimates show that methane on Maki Maki's
surface is crystallized and appears as rather large grains around one centimeter
in size as far ethane.
It looks like grains measuring around one millimeter in diameter and filling
smaller crevices and holes on the planetoid.
It goes without saying that in such low temperatures mamma's atmosphere is bound
to be extremely rarefied.
The density of gases just above the planetoid surface is approximately 1 billion
times as low as that in our earth, the eternal ice,
the surface is encased in,
cannot melt even on the planetoids closest approach to the sun.
Besides most of the solar energy reaching the dwarf planet,
rebounds back into space on account of the objects high Abido
for a long time, it was thought that Maki Maki didn't have any satellites.
However, in 2015,
a group of American researchers did detect a celestial body orbiting the
planetoid that's when its main parameters were gauged.
The object hasn't been given a name yet and for now is officially cataloged as
2015.
Still the satellite was informal in nicknamed MK two as usual,
a quick overview of the basic parameters to begin with.
MK two is a small and dark Celest steel body that reflects around 7% of
all light shed on it.
Its diameter may measure anything from 90 to hundred kilometers and the
radius of its orbit cannot be less than 21,000 kilometers as for
its orbital period. It is around 12 earth days.
The inner makeup of MK two is thought to be identical to that of Maki Maki,
however, suns would've vaporized.
The layers of Mehan snow that used to cover its surface,
besides with almost no gravitation forces exerted by the satellite to speak of
the gases molecules, would've floated away into space.
It is admittedly an extremely slow process that takes billions of years to
complete as Mac Mac's rotation period is anomalously long.
It gives grounds to assume that there is at least one more large satellite
orbiting it, but it still remains to be discovered.
Maki Mackey is currently located almost to the furthest point of its orbit,
which makes it difficult to investigate it.
However,
sending out an interplanetary space probe to explore it is hard sensible at this
point,
estimates show that it will take the spacecraft around 16 years to reach the
planetoid even taking into account a gravity boost maneuver near Jupiter,
just in 150 years.
Miya seconds in astronomical terms, Maki Maki will be closer to us than Pluto,
even though it will take a while sooner or later,
it will certainly reveal its secrets to us.
Dear friends,
it takes a lot of time and effort to make every video exciting and informative.
Every like you give us, encourages us and boosts our motivation.
If you'd like to find out more about this or that object and the solar system do
let us know in the comments, please subscribe. If you still haven't done so,
and you will never miss our latest updates, let's keep in touch.
The.